you know what is it inaccurate it was
just a literally
[Music]
hey guys it's a cast of descendants -
and we are at BuzzFeed and we're not to
find out which Disney Princess we are
come on be very excited be ready for
this I think okay first question what is
your favorite Disney movie Black
Cauldron I'm stuck between Freaky Friday
and Lady I'm gonna go with hunchback you
know what the Lion King what am i mom
wait a hunchback is good one - Black
Cauldron though next one is secretly you
think your enemies are envious of I
think I have to say I don't have any
enemies right that's a nice it to my
dreams maybe I almost want to pick that
just because you guys pick do it I'm do
it what are you most scared of war I'm
gonna go with war or more no he's
scarier eerie okay standing still global
warming scissors I feel like a Walmart
or Walmart is pretty scary yeah women
war is war and global warming are kind
of the biggest threats though I'm a
ghost little warning okay I respect you
guys what do you look for in a soul mate
I would either be passion or the pincher
or humor okay yeah okay I'm gonna have
to go with a sense of adventure
choose the talking animal favor I think
this is my favorite kind of shark
awesome I need a talking shark in my
life 100% gold Phoenix though I think I
won amounts yeah I had one in Cinderella
story it was very cute anybody who chose
animals can't have no soul minimus what
do you like to do with your time off I
feel like get out of town or I'm always
working
yeah I'm either get to go with my family
or I'm always working okay that sound I
like to go on rent and bacon I go it
gets good I feel it yeah what's the
secret to true love oh it's got to be
either communication compassion or humor
is there I don't know but yeah I don't
know I'll know when I find it I feel
like humor is like comes from the sense
of like happiness and joy and when
you're on the same page with that I'm
comfortable with someone yeah then it's
like everything is in alignment
you can have a chemistry with someone
that you do not love I'll know when I
find it
where do you like to have your first
date Sophie is always in decline sorry
no not because I only get clogged bed
it's like I go to bed every night at
9:00 just kidding she's at all too close
can you picture her on her own just like
a little glass and sipping some tea you
could find an index of you know what
divers do your birth date goes where we
going later tonight - come on hook it up
for a first date I feel like the movie
theaters perfect cuz you don't have to
look to it you talked to my mom for a
moment we're like do you touch the
person like you our first date what did
they do it's a club you know what I
don't have time to dig that's final
answer so pick an artist I want to
listen to Bruno Mars
Drake really loved Miley's basically me
but I love Bruno Mars for now your
little what is happily ever after that
is the question I'm finding inner peace
for sure 100 because when you do that
everything else falls into place right
no yeah okay when we look Justin like
what wait Rapunzel wait I got blonde I
got Ariel I got Rapunzel really
technically I need to get bail I wanted
to get Rapunzel like okay now we're
gonna take which Disney princes are true
of you guys ready you got a ladder going
to loosen uh-oh what why did I get B
[Music]
hurry about the way no I'm glad I don't
meet a one in the club with beeping up
with love China and Sofia